you revealed battlefield 2042 to the
world last month
how does it feel to have the news
finally out there oh well i think the
theory is when you
when you build a game and you're kind of
looking forward to announcing it you're
supposed to feel excited and pumped and
thrilled and all those kind of positive
words
yeah the honest reality is pure agony uh
the last couple of weeks before you show
off i think
you know you have teams that spend years
and years and years hundreds and
hundreds of game creators creating these
games and then you get this final moment
where you get to show the game to the
world and you never know what reactions
are going to be but of course super
happy to be able to show the game to the
world
it's something we're super pumped about
um so tell us about the game
and it's trademark game events that are
truly next level
you know not many times in your career
you get the chance to go through a
console
transition so when we got the chance now
to work on the new generation of
consoles
it really enabled us to rethink some of
the kind of core building blocks of
battlefield delivering a game at a scale
we've never done before and it comes
both on the land masses you play
battlefield on but also the player
counts you know getting the chance to
play with 128 players
on an army scale kind of warfare setup
uh we added a lot of really cool gear to
the game things like
grappling hooks wingsuit and then for
some really cool reason we like to say
like what about a real-time tornado
real-time tornadoes are cool right what
about adding one of those to battlefield
and then what happens if you take that
and you combine it with a wingsuit so
you can kind of propel yourself to the
other side of the map
you know these tornadoes they kind of
helping cut a ground way when you play
there's been more than a few play tests
in which you're in this really intense
situation
where you're honestly pretty screwed and
then a lovely tornado shows up and just
sweeps all the enemies in front of you
and like hey
that worked high five mr tornado uh and
i think those kind of
really big revolution moments that we're
introducing as part of battlefield 2042
is what makes the game special
you need to play on your toes every
single second because you never know
what mother nature throws at you
can you shoot like into and out of the
tornado
of course you can shoot without a
tornado
one good way of understanding that the
storm's actually approaching is just
kind of looking up at the trees if
there's trying this you're starting to
bend a bit too much
you probably are supposed to start
running because you're gonna get you
know sweeped up by that tornado sooner
or later
can you tell me how long the team has
been working on the game yeah so this is
a three-year cycle for us and that
really has enabled us to both take a big
leap when it comes to tech so we're
running on a completely new version of
frostbite which has enabled us to push
both visual fidelity and you know core
gameplay as a result
and really to kind of hone in on the
concept you've seen us talk about our
notepad specialists our new characters
and we've invested a lot of time and
kind of love and passion into the
storylines
and the worlds and you know the the war
we're portraying uh so we're super happy
to get a chance to do that so
dice and dice la have had a long history
with battlefield
but before we talk about the history
dice la just rebranded
so can you tell us all about that
christian uh yeah so the studio was
formed eight years ago as a way of
expanding the capabilities that that
dice had to build battlefield
we wanted to push this idea that we have
in the studio where we really want to
drive
quality in everything we do as a studio
and in order for us to do that in a
really good way we believe that you need
to be good at listening you need to
listen to the people that work
in the studio to kind of find these good
ideas these kind of
nuggets of good ideas that we then try
to turn into something real
and that sort of is ripple effect for us
it's this idea that great things have
small beginnings
and that's kind of what a ripple effect
is but uh we're super excited about the
name
we feel like it represents us it flows
well it's a good name
uh so the work that oscar and christian
have been doing for battlefield hasn't
even been revealed yet but christian
i'm hoping that you can maybe give us a
little bit of a hint uh
so i can't say that much uh about it uh
what i can say is this though is that
one of the components in this experience
that we're creating
is that we're adding some of the fan
favorite
maps back into battlefield 2042
but the entire experience you have to
wait a bit longer before we reveal what
that is
the team at dice announced hazard zone
at the reveal but
didn't say much we know it's being
developed at dice can you tell us a
little more about that
yeah i mean so battlefield 2042 ships
with three core multiplayer experiences
we've shown off all of warfare of course
christian and his team has something
special coming shortly that will show at
ea play live and our second experience
is called hazard zone it's a high stakes
squad based game mode with a lot of high
tension it's not your classic battle
royale it's a really contemporary mode
it's also something the team has been
thinking about for many years i'm really
looking forward to showing it to the
world it has some really special
components and it really kind of leans
into the superpowers of battlefield and
dice at the same time
so we'll show more later this fall just
a couple of weeks and months before we
launched the game in october